tanner howe going one an era right at
three
boys done everything you can ask of a
guy spot starting he gets
his second start of the year good
fastball good velocity but that sweeping
breaking ball is his pitch
for now we take our eyes to the field at
fenway
park and the red sox wearing their city
connect jerseys themed
for the finish line for the boston
marathon as tanner houck
faces tim anderson and we are ready for
the first pitch of baseball today from
fenway
and tim swings to fly it to right center
[ __ ] hernandez
watches it go tim anderson's first home
run
ever came at fenway and now on the first
pitch
he's got a one-nothing sox lead today
well i think our socks are going to be
looking away against houck and tim
anderson got a first ball fastball
took it the other way this is on the
outer third
one to nothing the good socks over the
bad socks
there's another piece of cheese here
swinging away high fly well struck into
the triangle
bond to run kiki he's going to get there
looks like the wind was playing some
tricks with that but he hauls it in
dallas kykel to [ __ ] hernandez who had a
four hit day yesterday for boston
and he'll ground it to ta first pitch
swinging
bounce it short dallas kykel wants to
execute just like that
throw sinkers away get him to pull it
last time out against the indians he
went five innings
gave up only three hits and generally
threw the ball pretty well got a no
d keiko has the sign
from grand all the pitch swing and a
miss
he struck him out sinker at 89
on our speed gun baffled by 89
basically middle middle so two down
here's jd
martinez
to third moncada at the bag easy does it
for out number three and dallas kykel
has a perfect first
your mean mercedes the league's leading
hitter and he swings and grounds it hard
backhanded by raffy along the foul line
deep at third one hop throw
not handled by dalbeck so the lead-off
man on mercedes
and that'll send up grandahl to catch
her mercedes on it first
shoveled into second one divers with the
turn got him for the double play
kind of low bridge the runner coming in
just a little bit you see drops he'll
drop down just a hair as you can see
right there and
then burner almost got up too early
has been busy and plenty of time to get
him
out gets the double play still looking
for win number one here in
21 2-2
fly ball right field in the corner it's
going to be caught by adam
eaton hunter renfro a home run and three
driven in
and he swings and hits a one hopper to
the third baseman moncada who will fire
to first
and that's it for the red sox in the
second garcia hitting 129
with no home runs against houck this
year the 1-0 is drilled into right field
back into his right hunter renfro renfro
leaps and he makes the catch
right on the edge of the warning track
hunter renfro
continues to impress in the outfield i
mean he gets a very good jump on the
ball he can run
he gets you know an excellent read on it
this is perfect play
perfect timing with the lead and take x
takes extra basses away
boy he made that look easy that was a
tough play that was a very tough play
because that ball was on a line
so i mentioned nine career lead off home
runs
for ta a chop to short charged by
bogarts throw to first late
that's an infield single and anderson is
the board
keiko looking for win number one
had some good stretches here in the
early going swinging a broken bat roller
that's
charged by monkatta the throw to first
in the dirt backhanded though and
dug out by jose abreu nicely done
by the big fella
oh there's a high drive that one driven
to left center
that ball's gonna be off the wall you
almost got it
he's gonna trot into second base he just
missed the home run
he'll take the double boy did he ever
just miss the home run that was a home
run swing big time i thought it was gone
easy i did too that ball was elevated a
little bit in the strike zone and dalbot
got all of it it seemed like he did
anyway
[ __ ] hernandez rounded out in the first
today
two and two for hernandez dalbeck at
second
and he got him to go out and ground it
to short exactly what dallas wants abreu
the stretch
and the inning is over that'll frustrate
you
turning back 1.2 million dollars he
doesn't need it the 2-2 swing and a miss
he struck him out with a slider
big sweeping breaking ball this time
gets an inside corner
on him and no contact it'll bring up
jose abreu he is oh for one today flew
out to center field
xander bogarts on a hop
save jose got there so we'll break you
on with a one out in field single here
mean mercedes
he reached on an error a breyon at first
adam fishing and down he goes for strike
three
two down for grand dahl and yasmani goes
after the first pitch and skies it to
left center field and it is high off the
wall
afraid to third he's coming home and
jazz has an rbi
double for a tune-up thing sox lead he
has drives in his seventh run of the
year
and this looks like another changeup but
he gets this one high and away
and for the first time in the game the
red sox have more than one hit in an
inning
and the tying runs are on base for
hunter renfrow
high chop here comes makati can't get it
rolls by everybody
martinez is in to score
and sliding into third rafael devers and
a red sox strike
that was trouble all over that chopper
is that a baltimore chop who knows that
ball was chopped and it looked like a
knock and then
he tried to do or die that how are you
going to bare hand this thing
yes he's going to hang aside
[Music]
go to first jose high throw to second
larry garcia playing chicken and they
did get the tag
at fenway josh taylor ready to work with
runners at first and third one out
swing and a miss got him to offer and
struck him out
bail in there so two away monkado will
climb in
go on to center field big rbi from
oncotta
and the sox have a three to one lead in
a seven inning ball game
kykel still on the hill that has been
bad news for the sox today i fly down
the line
that one headed toward the pole and that
ball is tucked in there
that's a home run [ __ ] hernandez
strikes did not hit in a mile but he
will
take it and the red sox are on the board
again and this is a one-run contest a
little innocent little
fly ball to right field no big deal i
think it might just sort of
slice foul but it just sneaks in yeah it
just stays in fear territory long enough
to wrap itself around the pole the only
thing worse is if it goes
dong off of that pesky pole yeah that
one really gets you
liam hendricks comes into this and he's
looking to nail down the save he's had
two opportunities he's been successful
50 percent of the time the era is up
there but that's largely one performance
tying run aboard and here's dalbeck owen
two
struck him out fastball and liam
hendricks can celebrate
the white sox have won the double header
opener
by the count of three to two